just because you play best friends
romantic couples or even family on set
doesn't mean those feelings translate to
the real world we're counting down the
top 15 disney star duos who just
couldn't play nice offset
we'll be looking at the reasons why
these stars couldn't find common ground
and how they moved on from it we may not
be dabbling in a love triangle
creating fake twitter accounts to trash
talk or fighting to share the spotlight
luckily many of these stars were able to
resolve their differences
and move forward in a healthy way after
time had passed and they had grown
while others seem to have left the past
in the past both options are valid as
long as it feels good and works for you
you know our first kiss was over the
computer
it seems the on-again off-again
relationship style of maddie and diggy
on the hit show liv and maddie
might have been inspired by true events
appearing to be the perfect couple
they started dating irl in 2013
after meeting in 2012. they seemed
inseparable
and confirmed their love quickly in
early 2016 with an engagement
announcement
unfortunately the two called it quits
towards the end of the same
year during the live and maddie finale
in 2017
dove threw some very visible shade
towards ryan tweeting that his character
diggy was behaving like
a boyfriend should ryan has recently
shared on social media that there may
have been
infidelity involved in the decision to
split ouch
we've all been in relationships that
were not healthy and like took from us
looks like both dove and ryan have moved
on and are dating other people
sometimes things that look perfect on
the outside just don't match the reality
you can't count to 10 on me
i count to 10 on you one two
three skye and debbie appeared to be
best friends while filming the hit show
jesse
often sharing behind the scenes moments
and gushing about each other on and off
set
the two seemed inseparable unfortunately
not everything that glitters is gold
at the end of the series in 2015 the
friendship turned sour
when skye accused debbie of online
bullying to which debbie responded in a
now infamous
tumblr post the two actresses unfollowed
each other in the same year and haven't
interacted online since
you get there you go through this story
with this person and
i'm angry about the lies that i was fed
by culture and the media
in early 2020 skye did confirm in a
tick-tock comment that there is no
longer any bad blood with debbie
it's nice to see that time kills even
the toughest wounds and we're happy that
this few didn't derail these two strong
women
on their career paths uncle josh riley
uncle josh we welcome girl meets world
with open arms when it premiered in 2014
as a spin-off to the original
boy meets world from the 90s having a
female lead with a strong female
perspective made rowan blanchard a great
fit
she's openly been an advocate for
intersectional feminism
and spoken out with support for the
feminism movement offset
it's better for everybody when you're
aware all of the privileges you hold are
all of the
things that sort of keep you back not as
much can be said for her co-star
and on-screen uncle uriah shelton who
very openly made his position on these
issues clear
after posting several photos that were
in sensitive and borderline
anti-feminism
he later went on to record to say that
rowan didn't necessarily like him
stating that they have a lot of
differences but we hope uriah is able to
look back at his actions with a
different perspective
now that some time has passed rocky i
think it's
upside down and backwards
great cece and rocky danced their way
into our hearts and shake it up but
unfortunately the stage wasn't the only
thing being shook
the two played bffs on screen but it
took a while for their friendship to
spill over into the real world bella and
zendaya have both spoken about the rocky
star to their off-screen friendship
stating that they were often pit against
each other on set to outperform one
another
after realizing how toxic these outside
voices were
the two were able to come together and
have been close ever since
sharing the love for one another often
across social media it's unfortunate
that women are often pushed to compete
against each other
but we're happy that these two were able
to work through it and hopefully have
shed some light on how dynamics could be
improved on the film set are those corn
dogs
ew uh do you know how dirty these drums
are laura moreno and ross lynch were our
favorite musical duo that we'd love to
ship in the hit show austin and ally
they devastated us with their breakup in
season two
we just aren't meant to be together are
you saying we should break up
but restored our faith at the end of the
series when the two get back together
and eventually married
these two had some good practice for
married life as they were often said to
be bickering on set like an old married
couple while the two reassured everyone
that this was just the way their unique
relationship was
it often resulted in others around them
feeling uncomfortable
and uncertain if their actions were true
luckily the two have stayed close
friends over the years and appeared to
be anything but toxic attending birthday
parties and concerts in support of one
another
oh my goodness we're sitting here in my
bedroom eating kung pao chicken it does
not get any more undiscovered than that
adrian kylie sabrina and raven simone
were our favorite 2000's girl powered
disney dream team
they were fierce and talented and lives
by their mantra
nothing can keep you from being a star
but only if you remember that friends
are more important than fame
uh at least they live by this mantra on
screen
off-screen saying a bit of a different
tune since two of the cheetahs had been
part of a separate girl group
called 3lw it was difficult for the
group to acclimate to come together as
one
things were just too clicky for raven
simone who was not
present during the third cheetah girls
film stating that filming the first two
movies
made her feel excluded from the original
team it seems that at least some amends
are being made in recent months
as raven and kylie have openly chatted
and made up during an instagram live
video
of course during this time some shade
was thrown towards adrian
it's good to see steps being taken
towards reconciliation
we're being filmed right now maybe we'll
get to meet ashton oh shut up ryan
sharpay and ryan were the sassy sister
and brother duo we loved to hate and
hated to love during the high school
musical years
turns out their attitudes followed them
off set admitting that they were
definitely not fans of one another
during the first movie both actors said
they hated each other with ashley
following up by saying
we were not good friends let's be honest
okay
we hated each other luckily enough time
has passed and both ashley and lucas
have confirmed that their friendship for
one another
grew following the first move and
throughout the sequels
i only get one chance to go to college
with my best friend
i love you so much hannah montana stars
miley and
emily which ironically is the same name
just in different order
were inseparable upon meeting onset in
2005.
miley confessed that their relationship
had dove into sisterhood
on and off the show four years later
however miley confessed in her
autobiography that the two bffs had
trouble getting along
stating we tried to be friends we really
did but it always ended in a fight
luckily a few short years after her book
miley and emily began reaching out to
each other
over social media and in march 2020
joined together on miley's instagram
with her introducing emily as one of her
best friends
we're happy these two were able to make
their friendship work off screen making
it truly the best of both worlds
you said to get a job not this one this
job's for losers
these two disney queens met on set of
barney and friends 18 years ago
throughout their childhood they grew up
in parallel on their own disney shows
and also co-starred in the 2009 flick
princess protection program
from that moment on both stars found
themselves busy with their accelerating
music
careers which took them in different
directions and in the company of
different friends
throughout the years they have followed
and unfollowed each other on social
media but have still shown love for one
another during big accomplishments and
big falls it's clear that both of these
women have mutual respect
for one another even though they aren't
close anymore which is a tough lesson to
learn
is this yours
merry christmas listen maguire lilo
and hill are part of one of the most
iconic love triangles in the early 2000s
that had us all
shook why is that because it involved
teen heartthrob
aaron carter younger brother of
backstreet boys nick carter
oh the drama after meeting on set of
lizzie mcguire
hillary and aaron began a two-year
relationship aaron went on to record
stating that he began to grow
bored and decided to start dating
lindsay at the same time
the ups and downs of their relationship
spiraled a little longer until he
cheated on her again
and they called it quits this was just
the beginning of the actresses feud with
one another which involved crashing
movie premieres and talking trash on
camera
luckily they both grew tired of the
drama and realized they weren't fighting
about
anything a few years later oh you hungry
just a little bit do you have a second
demi and joe met on set and shared a
kiss in the 2008 disney hit
camp rock but didn't couple up until
three years later
their romance was short-winded ending
only one month after it began
joe has spoken publicly about his reason
for ending things stating that demi was
working through some tough personal
struggles they've since become
friends we've all gone through so much
good and bad but
we've watched each other from the
sidelines with demi congratulating joe
over social media about his engagement
in 2016.
still pretty hard to overlook how
quickly joe bailed when things were
tough
would you still feel so strongly i'm
arguing on principle this is not
personal bull crap rachel glee had us
singing along and learning to boldly
move forward in life with their
strong-willed and determined characters
it seems this same sort of boldness was
felt on the set between leah michelle
and naya rivera in their 2016 memoir
naya confirmed that the two have very
competitive personalities which often
resulted in them
bumping heads absolutely i think it's
it's it's always on your mind
and it's one of those like little scars
in life she speculated that the issue
may have stemmed from her character
gaining more screen time
in the fifth and sixth seasons which
resulted in leah ignoring her and not
speaking to her at all
on set yikes wanna attach griffin wings
to your arms and fly
so you're saying that'll work all right
i'm in jake t austin who played selena
gomez's younger brother on wizards of
waverly place
threw some shade her way after she
appeared in the scandalous 2012 flick
spring breakers
jake tweeted when an artist's definition
of growing with their fans is creating
content they aren't even allowed to see
which was speculated to be about the
film
luckily the two were able to patch it up
with jake posting a heartfelt message on
his instagram in 2017
about selena following her successful
kidney transplant operation
hello thank god you're here ugly betty
was our favorite underdog
fashionista in the 2000s in the height
of the show's popularity lindsay lohan
was set to have a six-episode cameo
that suddenly got cut to four it was
fitting that lohan's character was
intended to be an
old nemesis from panting gone wrong
speculations to odd behaviors and mean
girl vibes
it's clear that whatever did happen was
quite toxic
sometimes people just don't get along
but it's too bad both people involved
were unable to take baha'i road
great it's even sort of kind of within
my budget
joe jonas clearly didn't know how to
play nice on this list for a second time
disney stars aj mashalka from the sister
band ali and aj
toured with the jonas brothers in the
early 2000s the pair started dating soon
after for only about a year
rumors swirled that joe forgot to call
aj on her birthday
and in return received a melted ice
cream cake in the mail but the real
reason for the split remains
unclear life isn't always shining on or
off set
as we can see from these 15 infamous
feuds we can only hope that their
indifferences have allowed them to grow
and learn
and not harbor on any toxic feelings we
might not be totally over it but we
really hope that they are
what sort of healthy methods have you
used to recuperate from a feud
we'd love to hear about them in the
comments below